another pc tactic is
playing to people's basest sexual
passions this is where
the the sex issue does kind of matter i
mentioned
earlier my interest in the the story my
political interest in the
catholic story is uh has more to do with
our understanding of freedom and rights
and
liberal modernity but my interest in
whap
my interest in the grammys my interest
in cardi b's performance
a couple nights ago that actually does
have to do with the sexual aspect
because
the left certainly since the 1960s and
the sexual revolution
but even before that the the left
recognized that by
arousing certain sexual passions
you can deprive people of their their
control over their higher faculties and
you can make them
easier to control i will uh spare you
the full whap performance between cardi
b
and some other musician i guess you a
musician i guess
uh uh during during the event but just
just take a listen
to uh to one brief passage
[Music]
um
so you can't even be mad
you can't even be angry if you just look
at this because
i i think you you know i've mentioned
this before i'm not
the most hip guy when it comes to
popular music
you know i'm not i haven't listened to
many
cardi b arias in my life you know i
haven't
haven't tuned into them so this really
is pretty foreign to me whenever
whenever i see this sort of thing and uh
watching it i i i'm i'm not the sort of
person who is
immune to desires of the flesh okay i'm
not i'm not saying
that uh there's no way to interest me
to you know however that does not
interest me
that performance does not arouse me in
the slightest because it is grotesque
it's not like
do you ever wonder when you when you
watch old movies
or you i don't know pick up a history
book or something
about 100 years ago we joke about it now
if a woman showed i don't know a little
a little leg you know a little uh just
lit you know there's a joke she lifts up
her skirt to show her ankle
men would go crazy because the culture
was so repressed the culture was so
focused on maintaining certain sexual
boundaries
that any time you would transgress it
even a little bit it was it was pretty
sexy
and then over time as as sexual mores
began to be eroded you would require
more and more
to stimulate you sexually so you know
then it became
women would wear even looser clothing or
then it became women would wear bikinis
and then it would be
it became you know even i was watching
some movies from the 90s over the past
few weeks
and even the way that sex was hinted at
there
and this was not that long ago it was
not nearly as grotesque as it is now but
because now we've lost all boundaries
because now we're in a culture that is
saturated by
high-speed internet pornography for one
and then even in the pop culture you get
stuff like wap
because of that we're just kind of
desensitized to it
and so you need more and more and more
to
stimulate you i suspect this is why you
see
pornography proliferating as it has
you're seeing now
porn getting so uh violent that you had
under the bush administration
the federal government prosecuting
pornographers because it was so
it was it became so violent sure if you
have a culture where
young boys are exposed to this at a very
young age you're just going to be
desensitized but don't you think
like if if you're finding whap really
arousing to you
hasn't something gone wrong with you if
that's what you need
to stay stimulated don't you think there
might be a problem with that
what we are told is that uh being able
to
whap ourselves all day long is uh
somehow the height of freedom right this
what we are told by liberal modernity is
that cardi b
you know bumping and grinding on a stage
with that other chick
and yelling about her whap that is the
height of liberation
and and empowerment and you know i'm
woman hear me roar but of course that's
not true
it you just look like prostitutes right
there's no
there would be no difference but if if
you were to show that video maybe 10
years ago
people would think it was porn right but
now it's actually mainstream
entertainment that kids can watch they
can't watch
dumbo the elephant on disney plus but
they can watch
whap on on tv is that empowerment no
is that liberty no that is the opposite
actually because the
conservative view of liberty the
classical view of liberty the christian
view of liberty all of them recognize
that liberty and licentiousness are not
only not the same thing
they're opposites the more you give into
your base
appetites and desires the less free you
will be the man who sins is a slave to
sin
our free government is built for a moral
and religious people it's unfit
to any other kind of people according to
john adams
the left though has made this excellent
little trick this very clever little
trick
where they've conflated those two terms
and now we we get very confused by by
all this sort
sort of stuff i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the michael knowles show to
check out the full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you